Expensive and expensive .
An Empire Building exercise or the creation of a new World Trade order.
It´s not
programs dominated by China it´s the program by which China
works. with other countries .
Tentacles that stretch from China through Central Asia to Europe
to the Middle East and Africa to India and Southeast Asia
over land and see through some of the world's most unchartered economic territories.
Defaults can always happen . Infrastructure is a risky business.
A project that when finished will have cost China and its partners trillions of dollars.
These are countries that need infrastructure.
The end of the day money will drive this process for .
Hello I'm Stephen Engle. Welcome to a look at how the economic
future of the world's oldest continuous civilization is evolving.
A new dynasty that's being built from Beijing on the foundations
of a project that is China's Belt Road initiative .
Fast trains are one of the symbols of modern China.
And so too is the pace at which the networks are being built.
Top speed for the trains. More than 300 kilometers per hour .
And rightly or wrongly in the eyes of some perhaps a reflection
of China's Belt Road ambitions.
Contrary to some other people's
misconception it's not a program dominated by China.
It's the program
by which China works with other countries
working with international financial institutions multilateral banks
So it's kind of cooperation.
Unfortunately some people missunderstood this as a kind of China program.
China wants to take advantage of these to promote its own interests with
nothing could be further from the truth.
Views on China are often mixed.
China builds up again enormous amounts of
goodwill by building infrastructure. These markets are
desperate for better metro system and road systems especially in
these small to midsize economies was not easy building infrastructure.
But at the same time there are some concerns .
And one refrain you often hear from locals whether
it's individuals or companies is that Chinese companies will
often win or come out on top
In the next 10 or 15 years or next 50 years.
The world will invest about 90 trillion dollars
in infrastructure mostly in emerging market and
developing countries. So whilst that sum is a very large sum
it's only perhaps a couple of percent or less of the world's
infrastructure investment. And it may be 3 4 5 percent of
infrastructure investment in Asia. So it is very big.
But we shouldn't overdo the magnitude of this in the context of infrastructure investment .
In its simplest form China is looking to revive the roots of the
ancient Silk Road with modern infrastructure economic corridors
and by road and rail linking major ports dry and wet.
To a maritime silk road that circles back to China.
But the reality is much more complicated.
When we have 86 countries.
It's very hard for me to say which countries is not part of the better
road you know initiative. And also for instance traditionally
when we think about Maritime Silk Way it might be west about .
But given the increased relationship between Asia and
Latin America it could be east or south west bound Africa.
So you see this is really an effort to promote regional and global integration.
It started out as unilateral policy to focus on
infrastructure a focus on relieving excess supply back at home
but it's a Volt's if inefficiently since then. And what we've
seen is a growing ecosystem emerge around those infrastructure projects.
A growing number of Chinese firms not just state firms
private firms all looking to participate not just because
of Belt Road but simply because the business opportunities
as a result of the infrastructure spend are beginning to grow and to expand.
So the policy today is very different to what we saw five years ago.
The Belt Road initiative is still very much in its early
stages being designed crafted. Of course there are some
projects already through to Central Asia and the road down to
Guadalajara in Pakistan. But it's in the early stages .
What we have seen so far is that there is a basic idea here
which is connecting the world to the station particularly .
Make no mistake China's leadership is serious.
The project has been enshrined in the Communist Party's constitution .
Rise or fall the Belt Road initiative will be seen as one of
the great legacies of Xi Jinping
President Xi Jinping said very very clearly
we are not going to build a garden in our backyard.
We are interested in building the beautiful garden with
beautiful flowers which will be enjoyed by all of the nations in this world.
I think the BRI is central to the strategy of China and the Xi Jinping.
It's about the story of the rise of China
and the reality of the size of China's economy and the reality
that the size of China's trade .
China is now almost equal in size and its economy United States
depends how you measure it. Some measurements it would be
bigger much more trade than United States. So the BRI is a
story of the rise of China and the openness of China.
So in China we say you aim high. You achieve something that will be lower.
You aim middle. You may achieve in you know the Lowest
So the Chinese people are very much ambitious.
But I want to say China to be ambitious for the rest of the world .
The ten economies by themselves account for
nearly 70 percent of the Belt Road GDP .
Chinese firms have won some deals in these economies but not too many.
They are struggling and in order to compete with a
Korean the Japanese American the European or the local firms
whether they're Indian or Turkish construction companies
Chinese firms are going to have to adapt. And that means collaborating
with foreign or local partners .
If an infrastructure is built in Southeast Asia or Pakistan or
Kazakhstan or thinking outside Africa. First and foremost that
infrastructure should be shaped by the country in which it is .
And that I think is extremely important in the whole execution of the idea.
It's not that China dictates not China saying this
is what your infrastructure must look like. That would be a famous
New maritime routes new roads new railways new pipelines
new port. China's superhighway is taking shape moving its
products to new markets and bringing the world's offerings into China.
Up next we'll weigh the risks versus rewards of doing
business through uncharted territory .
One of China's greatest challenges in realizing its Belt Road initiative
will be paying for it. The capital scope for
targeted projects ranges from 4 to 8 trillion dollars.
But its how it manages its money across countries with high risk and
poor credit profiles that provides one of the biggest unknowns.
Of the 70 or so countries China list as partners the sovereign
debt of twenty seven of them are rated as junk below investment grade.
14 of them countries like Afghanistan Iran and Syria are not rated at all.
Defaults can always happen.
Infrastructure is a risky business in the early stages.
And that's why it's so important to have the right kind of finance in the right
place and the right scale in the right time. And that's what
multilateral development banks tried to do to get involved in
the early stages where it's risky and manage that risk.
See the policy is very clear. The bank is inclusive and we do not
intentionally tried to grab as some people into this bank
because it's ultimately the decision making of the sovereign governments
and the door is open and we are inclusive.
If they're interested in joining and are working with other members
they'll most welcome. But each and every sovereign government
has its own ideas.
Too many government to government deals will
be a concern. But again the Belt Road initiative is evolving
and in its early stages there were many government the government deals.
Increasingly these deals are profit driven
not just between state owned firms and local firms with private
owned firms particularly we're seeing Chinese technology firms
beginning to move into the Belt Road markets and looking to tap
what is a very market driven consumer opportunity.
And what role should and will commercial banks play because they're risk
adverse as well but they're being driven by policy in many places.
Commercial banks have a very important role to play
particularly the foreign commercial banks because they provide a
robust due diligence process to project selection projects
screening and ultimately of course financing.
Chinese officials recognize this my conversations at the highest levels often
echo sentiments around where we need the private banks to participate.
We need the foreign banks to participate.
We're not going to fund all these projects. But more importantly we
don't want to see white elephants. We want these projects to be viable.
Transparency and good governance. They're among the
biggest challenges facing supporters of the Belt Road initiative
in Malaysia a change in government has seen the new prime
minister pare back some of the deal signed by his predecessor .
And in countries like Sri Lanka a debt default is steering the
project somewhat off course.
A couple of countries Sri Lanka is a good example.
The Chinese financed a big port there but it's
actually not very useful. It's not economics. So now the
Chinese have taken it over and I think we'll see that in some
smaller more vulnerable countries.
Infrastructure sounds nice but if it doesn't generate a
lot of business then it's not good infrastructure.
You can see that  Hambantota Port was
taken up without any proper economic feasibility study.
Sri Lanka ended up
getting to the chap as a result government to Sri Lanka had
to handle amended the port on a 99 year lease not just the port
but a vast area of nearly 67 square kilometers around that
For India which is the single biggest critic of the Belt Road
project it's also a question of national security .
China's biggest project to date runs the length of neighboring
Pakistan to the port of Gwadar on the Indian Ocean.
When you top what Maritime Silk Road. The fact  that today China has come to
quad control or controlling the states in some 75 ports in 35 countries.
Clearly that's not being done. Just with all commercial objectives in mind.
If you're very close to China then there's more nervousness.
India was a great example .
But some of the ASEAN countries you know they have to worry that
there's a strategic element to this .
China's lending a lot of money to Cambodia and Lao.
It's clearly buying friendship from those two countries and
they provide the kind of detail within ASEAN.
ASEAN operates on a consensus basis .
So if you're worried about South China Sea for example
you can count on Lao and Cambodia to stick with China prevent
ASEAN from doing anything that China would find objectionable.
Be out of witnessing a rapidly expanding
business of China and Indian Ocean region  Indo-Pacific.
We understand that China has decided
to emerge as a major maritime part we don't quarrel with that .
But what's happening has implications for us.
I think that when you have a rising power
like China.
Countries which are close
neighbors like India or countries which were the dominant
economic power like the United States have to think about their
position and they might get a bit uneasy because of the
strengths of China and the way in which China wants to quite
understandably and rightly in my view link up with the rest of the world.
And the rest of the world now means much more than
just routes along the ancient Silk Road .
Globalization connectivity 21st century transport and finance.
Is very hard to get clarity around the financing of these projects.
So even in countries such as Pakistan for instance
Many of these deals with the financing arrangements
around the deals are not made clear.
So there are some concerns but the Chinese well
local governments overpaying for Chinese for Chinese contracts.
The initial set of Chinese loans over the last few years.
You know a lot of it's gone to countries with very poor governance.
You know Venezuela is a big borrower Sudan Angola
Iran Pakistan. These are countries that may very well run into debt problems.
But here's an important. But Indonesia is a big borrower .
South Africa Eastern African countries. So I think China has
some good clients some bad clients.
And what you'd expect is that the projects would work out in the better managed countries
At the same time I would say there is a tendency for people to
focus on deals that were done five years ago but have only just
come to market whether it's a port or a rail project.
When you were deeply involved as we are in these projects and you see
some of the deals being done today they look no different to
those than any other multinational or any other large country would execute on.
So that part and it's the most exciting part.
It's the one that promises the most over the coming years .
That part's been overlooked
For port operators like Hong Kong's modern terminals .
The opportunities are massive. An estimated uplift of two and a
half trillion dollars in trade over a 10 year period.
Now coming up after the break we're going to get the word from
Mary's giant APM terminals as we continue to navigate the Belt Road initiative .
We're here Xi´an on the oldest of China's four great ancient
capitals home to the Han dynasty and the terracotta warriors .
But more importantly on this trip the easternmost point of the ancient Silk Road .
It´s here in Xi´an Muslim quarter do you really can get a sense and quite literally
a taste of the past. Much of the population
here are descendants of Arab traders who travelled from months
to get to China along the Silk Road.
It's no surprise to us that China is the world's largest trading nation
wants to promote world trade. And we see very much that Belt Road is an
initiative that supports that .
I think that the overall goal is to develop an additional
2.5 trillion dollars of trade over a 10 year period so that some of
these projects could be very interesting to us as a transport
and logistics provider. And broadly speaking if if the trade
growth does come. That's more cargo for our ships. It's more
throughput for our terminals. It's more units in our warehouses
Even in the shipping in the cargo business for decades .
Where do you see the biggest infrastructure gaps.
You have to keep building the connectivity. Our own research and I think
quite a lot of academic research shows that when transport
connectivity improves the cost of doing trade comes down.
And that has a beneficial impact on growing trade.
So our analysis has a 10 percent improvement in
connectivity reduces trade costs by 3 percent
and increases volumes by 5 to 9 percent.
So we see a direct connection between these two things.
And APM terminals should know the transport and logistics arm of the seafaring
giant Maersk has 78 port facilities in 58 countries.
Many of them passing along routes of the ancient Silk Road.
Very much we are looking at perhaps quite some
advanced projects actually within the Belt Road scope.
So for example in Bordeaux in Italy we've
co-investment with Cosco and Qingdao Port Group to build a new container.
So we're also working with Chinese construction companies
to build out new ports in Africa where we have some
interest in investing together. So very much seeing the
opportunity not just with in Asia but along the whole scope of
the Belt Road to collaborate.
So what do you think should be
the priorities in the opening days or years of this Belt Road initiative.
I think it's for us it's that is the transparency
is the area where we would really like to see the improvement
come so that we can very often stay in projects are done and we
only find out about them after the main players were already
reached an agreement. I think that's probably where the
international companies would like to get involved more with the EU.
I think he's very much communicating along the same lines
and the feedback to China. This is an area where improving the
transparency is critical to the future success of Belt Road
So plenty of roadblocks along the way but there is also a sea of opportunity.
Trillions are to be spent.
So who along the Belt Road stand to benefit the most.
I think they're shifting toward better managed countries and it's a more
general financing of infrastructure. So countries such as
Brazil or South Africa East Africa they have vast infrastructure needs
and there's a lot of potential for this to work out.
So if you think of it as a Chinese master plan for where
infrastructure should be. That's not going to work out. That's not realistic.
You know at the end of the day money is the
ultimate driver here. So if Chinese firms can provide elevated
or construct elevated light rail projects for instance in India
Even Indian players whether it starts or other construction
companies believe there's an opportunity there to make money by
partnering up with Chinese companies and they'll do so.
So at the end of the day money will drive this process forward.
Well I think the closest neighbours to China and those nations on the
route to Europe will be the early beneficiaries. That means
Central Asia and Southeast Asia .
But I hope very much that the links to South Asia will
strengthen particularly to India Pacific China India relationship
is the most important relationship in the world .
And secondly I hope that there will be strong benefits for
Africa to link up with the big fast growing markets of the world which are now Asia.
Actually if you read President Xi Jinping I
was a monumental speech in the first meeting.
He said Belt Road initiative would it connect with the other initiatives
proposed by many other countries. So we are very very
supportive of the Belt Road Initiative. Of course when
we are approached for financing the projects we will have to
see whether they meet our standards. For us the three basic
standards are as follows. Financial sustainability
environmental protection and the protection of the local
people's interests .
By the mid 15th century due largely to more efficient seaborne
trade as well as squabbles between the participating states the
original Overland Silk Road began its decay. It was about the
same time that the Forbidden City here behind me was being
completed to serve as the home to Chinese emperors for the
next five hundred years the revival of the old route is
indicative indeed of China's re-emergence as a global trading power .
I'm Stephen Engle. Thanks for watching .